what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so with alien covenant really coming out
this weekend what I wanted to do is make
a video where we just kind of run over
the different xenomorph types and I feel
like having covered the alien comics
we've really gotten feel like the first
two stories really aliens book 1 and
book 2 and so because of that I think it
gives us you know really kind of a
perfect ground to begin the process of
sort of expanding on the alien mythos
and then sort of building from there of
course you know the next one is
basically the female war which deals
with the introduction of the Queen
Mother which is this wildly powerful
xenomorph will actually talk about that
in this video but a little bit of
background for those people who are you
know of the age now where they're just
now getting into the xenomorph franchise
and don't really know anything about it
the Xenomorphs are the primary
antagonists of the alien series and
regardless of their type there are
certain common traits that all xenomorph
share ranging from a lifecycle of the
cocoon like egg to the facehugger to the
chest burster then the adult stage and
eventually the queen regardless of what
stage they are in the cycle they share
acidic blood and pronounced toughness
now take into account the story has
changed over the course of the movie
series as well as the comics and so
there are slight variations between the
movies in the franchise itself as well
as the comics a really good example of
this is that in aliens James Cameron
established that aliens procreate by
virtue of a queen that plants eggs but
in the original alien series there was a
deleted scene where Ripley ended up
finding out that the way aliens
basically reproduce is by taking over
hosts and then essentially converting
them into cocoons basically re
materializing them now because of the
fact that alien and aliens had two
wildly different forms of xenomorph
reproduction most people have really
just kind of gone with the assumption
that the the reproduction process seen
in the first alien film in the
director's cut is basically the process
is undertaken when no Queen is available
and so a human being or any kind of
organic material is converted into a
cocoon
so facehugger will impregnate a new host
it'll impregnate it with a queen and
then the Queen reproductive cycle will
begin so again it's just kind of
reconciling these two things in order to
make them work together now the life
cycle begins in the egg stage or the
cocoon stage depending on what you want
to call it when the cocoon detects life
it opens out and an ambush predator that
vaguely resembles a crown
emerges and attaches to the hosts face
cutting off the airway if they're
threatened but they put a two black
appendage down the creatures throat and
insert a larva into the host creatures
chest cavity now after a short gestation
phase the larva bursts out of the host
more often than not killing them in the
process and also during the gestation
process the larva absorbs part of the
host creatures DNA taking on certain
characteristics of the host creature
itself since the variation in the
xenomorph that have been revealed over
the course of the movies as so from the
larva stage it evolves pretty rapidly
often taking only a couple of hours to
grow into an adult form now in all the
forms of xenomorph again they share
acidic blood and toughen skin and
ability to survive the extremes of space
although it has been shown like it was
an alien 3 that when subjected to rapid
heating followed by rapid cooling
Xenomorphs are susceptible to these
extreme rapid changes in temperature and
will ultimately respond in relation to
these changes whether it be that they
just simply freeze up or they explode or
whatever the case may be now during the
adult stage is when xenomorph
are at their most dangerous when they're
adults they're usually significantly
larger than their hosts and despite
their size they're extremely stuffy able
to move nearly silently move just as
quickly hanging from the ceiling as they
do on the ground now while seeming to
have primate level intelligence they
also have a protective exoskeleton a
long flexible tail with a sphere like
end and an elongated don't head as well
as an inner mouth like a moray eel for
attacking their opponents the
exoskeleton seems to be made of
polarized silicon which is a heat and
cold resistant flexible polymer which
also protects it from small arms fire
and most melee weapons although high
powered shotguns pulse rifles and smart
guns can penetrate this exoskeleton now
the number one most powerful alien on
the list in the cinematic universe would
have to be the alien commonly referred
to as the newborn appearing in Alien
Resurrection the newborn was a result of
attempts to recover and clone Ellen
Ripley and the alien queen that was
growing inside of her virtually all of
the alien clones showed some human
traits the clone Queen was born with a
womb instead of the means to reproduce
an egg sac and gives birth to a humanoid
mutant now while the original director
Joss Whedon intended for the creature to
be an eyeless
pale white quadrupeds with red veins on
his head and
additional pair of pincers on its head
and to be the size of the Queen
replacement director jean piaget
decided to make it the human-alien
hybrid that appears on screen now human
features were also added to the newborn
such as red eyes and a nose to give
emotional value to his expressions and
regardless of his appearance it is shown
easily killing the queen alien when they
failed the bond and was only killed when
Ripley splashed acidic blood against a
hole in the spaceship window causing the
newborn to be pinned in his organs to be
sucked through the opening now the
second most powerful xenomorph shown so
far in the cinematic universe is the
Queen at maturity a queen Dwarfs the
common alien appearing to be nearly 15
feet tall
possessing acidic blood and a polarized
silicon of the drones as well as an
extra set of arms although when she is
in the position of reproduction she
appears to be trapped in a lattice
resembling insect legs and she has an
egg sac called an ovipositor on her
lower torso similar to a termite Queen
and simply begins the process of laying
eggs now unlike other insect hives such
as bees and ants there appears to be no
need of male drones to inseminate these
eggs generally the eggs hatch into face
hunters but an alien versus Predator
Requiem the stras brothers who directed
the film stated they wanted to add an
extra step to the alien mythos that of
being a way for a young queen to
directly deposit multiple transfers or
embryos like a face hugger and build his
army up before how to grow an egg sac
and which tail to defend itself now the
third most powerful alien and the
cinematic universe would have to be the
pretty lame featured in the alien versus
Predator comics and games as well as the
alien versus Predator movies it's large
and more muscular than the human spawned
aliens and it shows how much stronger it
is in the predators as a batch them away
and pins them with relative ease they
also show inability to build a hive
without facehuggers as a scene with a
pretty alien was able to deposit
multiple transfers of embryos into a
single host now the least most powerful
of the aliens in the Cinematic Universe
would have to be the dog alien or runner
alien as seen in alien 3 spawned from a
dog alien in a theatrical cut the only
difference between the runner alien and
the traditional xenomorph drone is that
it runs on four legs and is able to spit
acid from its mouth now aside from the
xenomorph in the main cinematic movies
there was also a series of non-canon
versions set in the fictional universe
of the alien films most of which
followed the wailing Johnny corporation
the united states colonial marines
following characters introduced in a
movie like Ellen Ripley Newt and
corporal Hicks the comic in books
explored other aspects of the xenomorph
lending insights into how the aliens
function and aliens kidnapped there
appears the mutated chestburster
hatching from a pink egg it emerges from
the host body as a black chest burster
it's slime trail carries a disease that
causes victims to go delirious and
eventually explode in the comic book
series alien colonial marines on the
water planet of Bracken's world the
aliens there are greatly different from
the other species perhaps assimilated
from whale like creatures they appear as
alien queens with their upper body while
the lower body is way alike with the
exception of tentacles now the white
Huibers appear in alien vs. predator
deadly subspecies a computer system
named toy created the white hybrids
which possess traits of aliens predators
and humans their blood is not nearly as
acidic as that of the typical xenomorph
and they are capable of speech and
wheeling firearms in addition to this
they're also led by a king alien instead
of a queen and their face hunters are
capable of impregnating normal aliens
eloise appears in aliens purged in alien
vs. predator pursuit created by savaris
5:03
she is a prototype combining the best
traits from alien Queens humans and
androids
enter debut she settled on another
planet with humans who have a condition
that we presses their chest Bursar's she
like an alien queen has a group of alien
warriors in which she's able to be back
a combined force of the Predators and
humans appearing in the aliens comic
series earth war female war and genocide
the queen mothers are the supreme rulers
of the xenomorph species even other
queens bow down to the Queen Mother is
similar to the queen bee they're
surrounded by orbs that contain the oil
jelly in which a drone or wire can
become a new Queen Mother in the case
that the current one dies and the Queen
Mother possesses telepathic and empathic
powers and they can call to their hive
from vast distances in aliens rogue the
robe or King alien was introduced
engineered by human scientists the rogue
alien was designed as a biological
weapon that would help rid earth of its
alien infestation while the scientist
who created the rogue alien dr. ernst
christ believed that the alien superior
size and strength would allow it to
dominate the queen
this theory is proven to be wrong as the
queen superior agility and speed allows
her to wear down and destroy the road
now the Praetorian serves as the rail
guard of the
and clean up hearing in multiple comics
in some cases the Praetorian also acts
as drones who inseminate the queens they
possess a crown shaved head crests much
like the Queen and in the comics have
been shown to have a second pair of arms
protruding from the torso like the Queen
itself the Praetorian are also the most
confusing alien casts to pen down
because different comic and video games
have taken creative license with the
alien species so in some media they're
depicted as the final growth stage of a
drone while other media portray them as
hatching from special eggs but
regardless of their birthing process
they're usually shown to be protectors
of the queen and are able to spit acid
as one of their attacks
now the empress is essentially the queen
of queens meaning that her hive has
expanded to the point where multiple
queens are needed to maintain the
numbers of the hive itself the Empress's
body and cress are larger than the
common queen as well as having three
spires on the crust itself the matriarch
was introduced in the original aliens
vs. predator game and is the oldest
known alien queen two spires appear on
the quest of the matriarch a bony Ridge
of spines adorn the back and the
matriarch face is scarred missing chunks
of flesh from around the head region
indicating extensive and experience in
combat the arachnoid appears in the
arcade game alien vs. predator and
besides being black and purple they
simply excel at jumping attacks the
chrysalis also appears in the alien vs.
predator arcade game being about the
same size as the Praetorian they possess
a greenish exoskeleton with a hard tan
carapace on his head back and forearms
and it attacks by rolling itself along
the ground like a ball another type of
xenomorph appears in the alien vs.
predator arcade game nicknamed the
defender and it has a bluish tint to its
carapace and is extremely resistant to
projectiles and hand-to-hand attacks in
the video game alien 3 the gun there is
a variation of the runner alien seen in
the movie alien 3 there's also a fully
mature Superdawg alien that's capable of
launching purple balls of acid from its
mouth now there are also flying aliens
that appear in several video games like
aliens extermination and the NES version
of alien vs. predator the flying alien
possesses wings and is nicknamed the
alien dragon in the extermination video
game and in the kinder toy line there's
also a flying alien queen also in the
arcade game alien vs. predator the
infect ID was introduced in this
instance a face hugger was modified for
use as a bio weapon and instead of the
victims being sedated House of
altered face hunters were put into a
zombie-like state and attack any
intruder in the area and if the altered
face hugger
implants a predator they go into a
berserker rage attacking anything that
moves the k-series has introduced an
alien vs predator extinction by dr.
Samuel kadinsky the primary difference
in the k-series xenomorph is their
yellow and white color instead of the
black color seen and the typical
xenomorph species a hive war eventually
destroyed them as the natural genome
wars attack the k-series
in an effort to keep their gene line
cure the carrier was introduced in alien
vs. predator extinction the carrier
alien is a xenomorph that evolved from
the Praetorian their exoskeleton is not
as thick and they are more vulnerable to
fire but they carry six to twelve
facehuggers on their spines and it can
even harm facehuggers at its enemies
the ravager was also introduced in
extinction and is one of the largest
alien species ever created their claws
are exaggerated and able to decapitate
enemies in one slice the claws are also
powerful enough to tear through Armour
and even a starships hole they're also
able to heal much faster than the common
xenomorph and are single-minded killing
machines making no effort to spare
enemies for the cocooning process in
alien vs. predator 2 primal hunts the
pred a lien queen is first introduced it
results in the alien facehugger
impregnating a predator and the
resulting drone evolving into a queen
now how the pret a lien appears is
according to the media as they vary from
coming book and video game appearance in
the video game series the print alien
possesses a stockier physique and
dreadlocks similar to the predator
themselves the mandibles have replaced
the inner mouth in the normal alien but
in primal hunt the Preda lien is capable
of using its mandibles to instantly
crush and consume the head of its
enemies and the arcade game alien vs.
predator the razor claw was first
introduced its coloration being closer
to purple it has extremely large claws
on its fingers it's quicker than a
normal xenomorph and is capable of
cutting a human in half it's also
believed the razor claw is the result of
genetic manipulation but it's never been
verified also in the arcade game is a
Smasher which appears brown and green
and attacks by charging like a ram like
most seen Elmore's in the arcade game
they were added as variety of creatures
to fight so little information is known
about them in the aliens colonial
Marines the crusher alien makes an
appearance having a much wider and
heavily muscled body than the nola
xenomorph as well as a wider crust the
crusher is able to smash through steel
doors if needed
to reach its prey and finally I'm a PC
version of the aliens vs. predator game
there appears to be a Zeno Borg they
appear to be both mechanical and
biological and can simply fire laser
blast but with that being said guys I
thought it'd be kind of fun to just run
over the different versions of a
xenomorph that exists in the realm of
pop culture and media and so on and so
forth let me know if you guys still want
to see more Zeno more stuff we still
have like the female war which is
actually a pretty cool story it features
the return of Ellen Ripley in the alien
comics I like it it's really one of my
favorite ones but if you guys are new
here to come as explained and you want
to see more videos like this make sure
you drop a like button or make sure you
hit the like button also make sure if
you hit the sub button to become part of
the robbed Court and yeah I will catch
you all later peace
[Music]